Las Vegas Nevada back from Vegas
everybody back from Vegas Russian
not-so-fresh um can't get out of there
fast enough every time I go well we went
there first of all just so people are
aware I didn't post anything in social
media I don't think you did either now
but Brian and I were down there for this
event I was there for one night Brian
was there for the weekend I had weird I
had to perform they paid you to just
make an appearance making parents and I
had to probably trip and gold right I
beat the [ __ ] are you bowing yep you
KITT you crushed me in bowling there
that was a good time yeah the first
night thank God you were there
thank God you were there first of all
because we had to do well there was a
convention for well as a tournament for
gamers but hold hold
these were board gamers now now hold on
do you know the gate board games are an
11 billion dollar industry they're an 11
billion dollar industry and these were
there was a board game and I had to pay
for yep how did stand for a bunch of
board gamers great audience sweet people
smart got it because they play board
games white yeah oh wait low anyway
probably yes a lot of low blood sugar I
[ __ ] the whole vibe up cuz I went
because you know e games I know he games
I grew up in he games doesn't my goddamn
dick I know e games they all that stuff
yeah and I went there you go oh no it's
Borg inland Oh like monopoly I thought
they were joking me - I thought I
thought they're trying to like you know
people try to make be funny around yeah
are you oh like monopoly means like no
god no and they started ripping that's
what I aimed that was my joke I go I
have so many board games Oaks I can't
wait to try them out on you guys like
but most of them are just clue and
monopoly related come on yeah man it was
it was interesting vibe because the
people went there for great but then you
know there's this whole like culture
because there's marbles around and
they're careful with models but yeah
what do you mean well yeah they were
yeah I don't know how modely they were
well they're not they're not [ __ ]
Kate Moss models they're like they're
pizza grandma their profession is very
good they're Vegas model a lot of makeup
a lot of silicone and hi you
squeezed into those outfits it's very
hard to breathe in a Vegas hot girl the
interesting way to make a living
it really is you squeeze your body into
the most ridiculous little piece of
camouflage tonight that one guy who
wasn't associated with the event we were
with he was in there cuz it was that
game work so it's open to the public but
it was closed off too so people could
come and go filter in and I was sitting
there and I took a picture of this guy
and he's this older rich rich dude and
just like you see these chicks 1,500
I'll [ __ ] them and you know what I'm an
yeah I went oh good luck with that yeah
well that's where they feel sick yes it
should it should because he's right
I don't think he for a lot of them he's
pleased right
he makes Harvey Weinstein look like like
the rock like he was not a very
attractive man no no no no there was a
[ __ ] Jabba the Hutt but with worth
worst teeth yeah there there was well
and and the women the hot girls in Vegas
I was thinking about your life is a hot
girl you are there you probably dance or
you cocktail waitress you in a stripper
so yeah so you're either you weren't
you're in the club scene yeah in the
local club scene where you're working at
a club your hostess your cocktail
waitress you they're tight casinos 11:00
at night Luna and I you can't obtain a
lot of vitamin C or D that's right like
in any of that and then you're on
Instagram and they're working out during
the day you're working out during the
day when you wake up at 4:00 or whatever
it is but then think about this B then
also think about the people you're
meeting so you're in that same industry
and then you're meeting people like the
guides in that in case you're meeting
terribly dude yeah guys not even tell
guys just guys just guys just bang yeah
just yeah and they're gonna pay your
money everyone but I feel like
everyone's a mercenary economist guys
the girls like it was just it was just a
weird vibe for me well the thing about
like life Oh job is to you wake up and
then you're in a club so let's say let's
go through it your cocktail waitressing
at least that's a job and you're getting
tips and your you know tits out asset
the but a lot of times you're just
atmosphere so your atmosphere like you
are at this event so what does that mean
you're
hold up to the nines and in shoes where
your feet your feet are squeezed in they
look like they look like what you take a
towel when you're wringing water out of
just toes are like can't breathe
somebody help me please let's just cinch
punch the [ __ ] up and you're there and
you're walking to some red bottoms that
you gonna take seven shifts go for it I
got it you got six layers and makeup
your hair is all done it just takes
forever and then you stand around you
stand around and you you fend off or you
accept just mail mail clumsy mail energy
but the ones we were talking to she was
saying how they're like oh we're here
and then I gotta work tonight at this
club and she goes we got to be there cuz
you know that it's a big nights
Halloween weekend there's a bunch of
high rollers you're coming in yeah and
we're there and I'm like wait what do
you mean you're there like well it'll be
a bunch of guys they want girls so they
pay us this state you know hang with
these guys to make them look good that's
right and then she goes and we
encouraged him to buy champagne just
girls like champagne it costs more I'm
like oh my god that's right so the guys
like yeah that's what you want that's
what we're gonna get right I'm like
doing a shame yeah and the daughter the
table cousin I'm very glad I was Billa
yeah well your daughter's not going to
because you're gonna be in her face and
yeah her life how weird is that that's
the whole bummer and then I go hold on
so these high rollers they're sitting on
the VIP table or whatever in the club
and then you guys are there but no one
hooks up with nothing she goes no they
just want to appear that they're with
hot chicks so here's what I think here's
what the smart move is if you're a hot
girl in Vegas I'm being dead serious
about this get your money get your money
what I would do is this I would probably
dance at a club and then I would I would
get five super-rich clients and I would
[ __ ] them
and I would impair oh hold on Roman hey
hold on
dad hold on bro you're a dad hold on and
they'll hold on daddy your dad call me
daddy no carry on and this is what I
would doing I do I fats out your your
daughter at 17 is gonna rewind this cim
yux io5 well [ __ ] Ron
gee Mike but I'm gonna defend it no no
I'm what I'm saying is this if he's like
a lot of Vegas and and you're going to
be atmosphere or you're going to be
whatever that is then do yours
a favor save yourself the time and
energy and sock away money and have a
plan which would be you go dance I guess
you can go dance looked it up blood make
a grand but more importantly get find
four or five dudes that are rich but
kind of good-looking you're gonna you'll
find who are nice nice guys good-looking
and have [ __ ] loads of money and then
just work out a deal
it's just hooking up because you hook up
anyway so fine rich dude so you go I
have I have five guys that come in let's
say once one weekend so it's what I'll
even go it's what every one guy every
weekend cool
this is hey now I got you 40 grams cover
that weekend these scumbag at 50 grand a
month
hey ladies here's the plan I prompted
five guys just get [ __ ] every month
it's blood property then the other which
is you know atmosphere wasting all your
time then you wake up at 35 with no
skill set but you've been hanging around
well either way and I have skill set
either when we are playing you know at
least you build a nest egg and you can
buy some property you know and I've
known some women who have done that and
now at 40 they're glad they did I don't
know man I mean you don't actually
typically have real set on business
plans for [ __ ] from me you know what
they typically happens though they say
is that that a lot of women who are
escorts will do this and then they'll
hook up with one regular and then that
guy ends up marrying him happens all the
time and that's what happens happily
ever after that's the Cinderella story I
would I would imagine the majority of
these [ __ ] don't need a charm please
well that's what they're and doesn't get
marriage that's that be the minority be
but what happens is like some guys like
you know what you're at you're pretty
cool let's get married even though you
[ __ ] over how many guys everyday money
there are guys that do that does that be
the exception though no but see cuz
here's how the women play it I know two
guys this is how they play it they start
they start they get the one guy who's
cool who they kind of like who's got
money who's really nice to them and they
start banging him for free
you start spinning your web that way and
all of a sudden he feels special you're
like you know what I don't
this anymore just want to hang with you
and the guy goes you don't did I just
did I just find a hooker with a heart of
coal now I get it be I get you talk
about the exception - no yeah am i
talking about the excess what happens to
most wars most of the happens escorts
don't meet a rich gang yet man what
happens the old escorts what happens the
old we're we're old escorts go drugs I
mean they become drug addicts and really
I do there you go I don't know oh no I
really don't cuz I see the old elephants
in Vegas I don't know where the old
where the old escorts go what happened -
well I know a lot of times you get into
real estate selling real estate and
stuff right no no oh no offense all due
respect anybody sells real estate I mean
if you if they do do that though real
estate least you gotta you know get
certified and stuff like that it's work
yeah god bless well we know that this is
the oldest profession in the world and
we know it happens constantly right yeah
I don't shun anyone I don't mean that
she's sell it but what happens is it
today some probably do it for a while
and then get another stuff right get
their goose egg yeah yeah or they do it
they go they do it for six years and
then they say what the money doesn't buy
happiness that one guy we saw he's worth
I don't know how much millions hundreds
and hundreds of millions keeps you
lonely my buddies my buddies although
the problem - is this personality sucked
you can't buy personality my dress the
way he treated girls and really that one
guy we walked in and he had the six
suite and he goes welcome to the [ __ ]
palace Chateau [ __ ] a lot Chateau [ __ ] a
lot all right man well we don't talk
like that where we're from
along with laughing so hard you were
laughing so my god it was great
then he shot you showing us around and
there's this big like Golden Swan I
think that's where the girls [ __ ] you
know what man
I left I was like you know oh my god
Brendan Schaub has to get out of there
you know something too much for me do
and then how about because there's like
hors d'oeuvres and stuff in like finger
food like chicken fingers after you've
done whooping cow's ass and bowling
there's like chicken fingers stuff like
that town ball 260 because I know
there's no bumper yeah I didn't every
shoes the ball that I needed a bowl 140
not big
my shoes hey so I don't know where I was
going that story oh but there's no food
so we want to eat afterwards
so there's someone's like oh my god one
of those moms like oh my god just great
sushi night story oh my dog what do you
think what is a weird name
unless you're like if Nobu and I'm like
there's a Nobu and this [ __ ] strip
much like y'all except Jesus we go there
it would not Nobu it was now boo-boos we
go on they're like alright well there's
no good
it was no no it was no Baba's but the we
knew we're in trouble even Brian some
foodies because the albacore tuna came
there like the sashimi and there was
like pico de gallo on top of there was
like Tyson diced tomatoes and I go I'll
get Brian off [ __ ] bring us that can't
be healthy and like that let's just eat
it man so we both ate it and by the way
as I was heating it up in the kitchen
you didn't see when I look in the
kitchen and there was uh because it was
a big like kind of a group and we're
wood sitting kind of in this and I look
in the kitchen
and there's the soapy dirty water on the
floor and guys are moving around and I
went fish in that soapy water is a very
bad combination it was like a dirty dirt
walk know what the other red flag with
all white dudes what's up bro well kind
of see how my god damnit and at dark see
why don't you ladies couldn't see
anything
why aren't you agent yeah yeah it's very
change and brought that diced tomatoes
me and Brian ate it a couple of the
rolls rolls were all right not that the
fish was a little slimy yeah so that's
where I went something's up I false
thought so I leave everyone right I felt
sleazy already just being associated
with this thing go back to my hotel fall
asleep wake up albacore tuna wet hey yup
not good we're coming out we're coming
out coming out I'm talking I do it I for
whatever reason these last podcast I've
been either throwing up or [ __ ] my
pants yeah I'm gonna have to book it to
the back I'm just oh yeah and then I was
good yes he now I didn't throw up what I
did was I took 26 booze really about 26
booze I was like hey man yeah and and
then I called you and I said I'm sick
you know Brian just hate did that fish
make you feel sick on it oh my god I
knew it
yeah I did but when I say I was good I
threw up and then you know how you're a
little better after food poisoning throw
up but then the whole next day I was not
feeling great and I'm I'm here / oh your
flights delayed five times that'll get
you that's a really good time that's in
parallel not a get you especially
Southwest Oh
so I [ __ ] hate Southwest we're so big
- you got to sit in this shoes off the
West is resting in the middle of shoes
of [ __ ] airwaves it's the worst
anyways so I land in my dad's in town
and we're taking Tiger to a pumpkin
patch
cool man I have zero downtime I [ __ ]
race home get in the car and load up
everyone drive the pumpkin patch well no
one did the research that pumpkin patch
isn't there anymore we drove out for no
reason really yes God but god damn it
man god I understand that stuff that's
the [ __ ] horse hey sorry hey how
about this like the time in college I
convinced all my buddies to go to a car
show and I misread the ad in the paper
and it was the following weekend but we
drove like two hours he kids right it
was like god dammit we show up there's
no cars yeah
how about this my my son my neighbors
like we want to can can Nolan come over
and play and I'm like sure and I'm there
alone with my son and we have a lot of
kids in the neighborhood and all of a
sudden I just see Nolan leading about
seven kids and they're just running
toward my house and I'm uh whoa okay
well here goes the Mary that's a lot all
right but I don't mind we'll figure it
out you know throw them in the backyard
playing a bull ISM next thing you know I
see a father running way way
and no one's already in my house up with
my son another kid rather and my son's
out there there's rolling around playing
around wait no I why what because they
all have lice they owe their life in
festive oh my god there's oh hi skinny I
call my wife I'm like what do I do she
could spray his head I have him out of
the empty Lao Tsing tea tree oil spray
he'll turn off spring him he smells like
a [ __ ] tea tree I'm spraying his head
I'm rubbing his you
the kids leave no you know when I was
like what are we gonna do now that's you
know it's already Isis lice but Isis
lice Howard likes to live other comes
down she goes I think I have it and I go
you do she goes yes so I look in her
head I can see the lice I may be a
member like she knows that's what
happens we all started she makes me see
my kids my son played all day he's
definitely got the old nice the old life
Elias is everywhere
it's weird it's still problem yeah tiny
I saw him as first time I never seen you
like that you can see crabs I never had
crabs in time I leap you yeah you see
crabs it'll look like crabs do they
bring crabs up I know it's gross per STD
crabs you type in crabs you can get
[ __ ] under the sea like we don't want
that but you can see them apparently
look at those little things you all you
know what those do look like crazy
shirts and those hanging out around you
did they get dug it right on your dick
and they get in there too they get in
the old skinny skin now is it it's crabs
a real big I haven't heard of someone
having crab since I was in high school
ah I don't know I guess they're sexually
transmitted technically you can get them
from a toilet seat but I don't think so
I don't I think that's the myth brother
anyway either way man either way mother
nature can be a real [ __ ] either way
if you're a girl and gifts on crabs or
you're a guy I mean it's game old stuff
man I mean if you spread the rumor oh
yeah she gave me crabs uh
it's a tough one I don't care how hot
yeah well I figured it out so what I if
she's really hot I'll be like yeah girl
what's going on now though let's shampoo
that down over there I couldn't sleep
last night so I got on my phone I read
the news on my phone and it's sewn
tagged me in a video like shop check
this out and it's this whoever sent that
to me thank you but it's this I'm
watching it and it's like looks there's
like a mom and a dude hunting in Africa
they killed this line with a huge main
they're taking pictures like yeah yeah
and like guy will just guess what
they're gonna do with it and then she
like I go oh [ __ ] and they put up like a
GoPro camera on a rock and this line
another big one comes running in and
like you're Jing kuzey wait I'll just
watch it like this that scares you
crazy so I think it is fake though is it
check it out how the [ __ ] you find an
ordinary video online seeking vengeance
for the slaying of his body look at his
face
the video starts with a young woman
rifle in hand behind a huge lion she's
supposedly just shot in South Africa
then her companion appears and they pose
together boots there's a little goofing
around look over the hill another lion
is approaching as the unsuspecting
wanders out of check out the face
kill me little does he know as he
fiddles with the cameras buttons the
Lions about to take revenge in the chaos
you heal him look fake fire followed by
another shot the lion wanders back into
frame he's unhurt and the two hunters
are nowhere to be seen the video is
getting a lot of attention and it sure
looks legit this is real as one agent
viewer but many folk this is real one
YouTube y NY here we go analyst Connor
McCourt to give us his take in the fancy
this is the amount of detail and the two
Lions Mane's does not match there's a
lot of smoothness in the mane of the
lion here and here there's a lot of
detail I'm seeing a different colour
between the two yes I believe there's
something fishy you're Brian two years
that does look like the MGS then he
shoot then he comes back in a frame he's
pretty cool though yeah anyways I
thought that was real this morning and I
freaked out I eyes and I found a bunch
other Curtin events I send a change I
was reading them all somebody DM me
something it made me cry made me cry it
was a picture and it was a still picture
and there's a guy I dress up like
spider-man thank you whoever sent this
to me guy who dresses up like spider-man
and he goes and hugs he shows up in
hospitals for cancer children and his
kids bald and you know it's gonna getcha
and he's holding the kid and the kid
hold on it made me want to cry oh I
can't watch those that still image where
I just was like what a good guy what a
good person said it was like Chucky
let's let him be he said this guy gets
parently guys a story and he does what a
good person
yeah Thank You spider-man take it um
anyway man I'll start my fun stuff sorry
sorry to bring it all down man um anyway
yeah and we'll put Vegas to bed yeah it
was kind of creepy going by Mandalay Bay
though huh it was yeah and they got
seeing those uh we're gonna in Vegas
talk on this but it was crazy scene
mentally bay how I don't know I know how
I be not give me the best rates either
still alright I mean it's not you know I
think you'd like $59.99 a night or some
[ __ ] to get traffic in there but you
know not the best deals I don't know
yeah it's weird seeing those bunkers
like the big jet fuel bunkers that is
fine yeah like you could go drive by
them when you're going back out Airport
and you shoot that you you you shut that
room down right forever so it becomes a
memorial what do you do with that yeah I
think you closed it off I think you're
just noting its place - I mean you break
it up yeah go and break that up I think
so too and and not a memorial don't just
just yeah break it up yeah brick that
[ __ ] up erased that piece of [ __ ] from
the world you know I agree yeah um I
won't always wonder you because hotels
have big problems with suicides and
Vegas no but my buddy used to run a
hotel and yeah he'd run all over the
country and the suicide was a huge
problem in Vegas because you can't get
out that's right
most hotels well people don't actually
usually jump out so in hotels people do
all kinds of themselves
we know the number one place for suicide
for hotels where in where's the shining
this film ooh yeah you don't say in
Denver uh out in the outskirts yeah uh
not for you what's going anyway cancer
suicide let's move on to you watch
fights I did watch the fights
I watched the SAP all oh yeah I watched
the Demian Maia fight
love Demian Maia that was a tough one
for him she looked very tired before
that I watched the bronson i watch the
bronze does the main of this yeah I just
watch the main events I didn't watch
Linacre how was that fight he looked
great yeah then Munoz looked great had a
great guillotine
uh yeah Demian Maia go ahead be just a
tough night for Brazil in a way I mean
Damian I just looked tired he looked
tired doesn't wait tomorrow yeah I'm too
big for the division very dirty too much
weight
yep he just looked so drained and and I
don't think he's getting better either I
think he's taking fights too soon he's
cutting the weight of good rest were
like oh we got Kody
coming tense just it's just trouble stop
that was takedown series well he looked
like he was tired even his takedowns
looked like he was kind of diving for
that single or diving about double and
staying there and maybe it was because
Kody was Kobe Kobe was sprawling hard
but it's always world class yeah it just
looked really tough okay was a little
alarming up you're Kobe fan is you know
he was getting kind of pieced up by in
that first round yes when before Maya's
how you get tired in the first shot no
fight at 170 is crazy but before David
Mya before the tiredness kicked in he
was kind of winning to stand up war
which if you're a fellow 170 are going
well well what do we got here mmm-hmm I
think Kobe gets on the mic it was
hilarious do you yeah filthy animals
place is a dump and your bunch of filthy
animals see you later
well that's how to not win friends and
influence people but I guess no I get
Rick I want to talk to you about talking
about well a couple things one the
reason I watched the fight first was
because of that cuz I I appreciated that
he was unapologetic I don't I don't
appreciate maybe what he would say it
wasn't very diplomatic but I appreciate
that he strict but stuff but it stood by
his guns he was like I'm not apologizing
because he took a lot of heat from
people calling him all kinds of names in
Brazil if they didn't millions they
didn't make it very welcome for him
which you went through yeah when you
were fighting another legend yeah so you
know but that wouldn't be that's not how
you would handle it and that's not how
you did handle it no I mean what Kobe
did though it was smart it's brilliant
just create like controversies yeah cuz
now you know he just I mean he beat the
breaks off Demian Maia you know up way
worse and would lead
so now all in one storm out is Kobe
fight for a title where you know you did
you see did you see Woodley's tweet
response to that yeah it's pretty funny
I think Woodley's Hoff I think I think
you know Woodley just needs to do
something to get us excited to watch him
fight he's a phenomenal talent but you
know he needs a heel like this he needs
someone where we wanna watch Woodley
fight you're telling me it'd be a big
pay-per-view if Woodley fought the word
of mahse with all wonderboy know that
Robbie ball again no yeah if you got if
he fought dos Anjos no but you need a
guy like like Kobe or like a dare until
or Mike Perry I think he needs I wonder
Kobe if Kobe tries to stand with there
and tell I think he's gonna have a it'll
be a very short night friend as tough as
Kobe is because his he's a wrestler and
jiu-jitsu guy but I think that till is
you know well then again the game plan
would be to take till down and wrestling
yeah if ice not happen but the issue
here is for so Kobe versus Woodley is a
legit no possibility because of their
because the wrestling would would cancel
it
no because Kobe just beat Demian Maia
yeah and Willie doesn't have a fight so
if you have Maz at all if you were to
beat wonderboy I guess you probably get
Maz with all this shot but welterweight
division
UFC the best it's ever been yeah yeah so
many good fights yeah so so many good
fights what do you think of Kobe I know
he's coming off a big win but what what
are you where do you ready to stand up
in the top seven guys uh although i
don't know i mean i mean you know he
went and did his thing I like the way he
was kicking Damien's legs like the lower
leg I mean it always has issues with
kids yeah Keegan and I thought you know
he was Kobe versus Woodley would would
be a fun fight Co Weaver still is a
difficult matchup for him
Kobe versed parries interesting fight
there's so many good fights yeah
Machida my boy Machida locked out the
game of thrones I told our boy Todd
filming on it man you know I'd do if I
fought again which I'm not I was just
hypothetical I'd walk out to Game of
Thrones yeah but there's two problems
with when Machida walked out Game of
Thrones they didn't turn the volume up
so it sound like he was walking out to
[ __ ]
in or in here I didn't hear us terrible
yeah it was like and then which is all
Game of Thrones play it on the flute I
was like what is that like right on the
side of Caitlin opposed that's game of
throne can I ask you a question Emma
cheetah's when you know two year layoff
you know can I run since a monster
can I see your question do me a favor
what do you think that you could do take
six maybe eight months do a shitload
erodes I mean a shitload erodes dodge
you solder show up you're back looking
like a [ __ ] pizza I mean just yeah
yeah sure with huge tits okay and just
Jack to the gills and take one bite and
then get caught and go I don't care and
you see it easy money yeah yeah yeah it
took steroids oh no I guess you guys
gonna let me fight again [ __ ] off see
you then a WWE run off yeah no no I need
you here I know WWE just be just just
shoot the [ __ ] up I'll shoot you in the
ass myself though take needles just in a
do a crazy psycho ball blood doping I
mean [ __ ] I want you the color of a
plum and I don't want to see your neck I
just want you to be a giant who would I
fight um listen
nah Brock yeah maybe Brock he's just
such a monster though I'd rather you
fight somebody who that would be my
easiest matchup we might fight steep
ain't no [ __ ] night Brock can't have
that matchup all right you can't strike
oh there you go
yeah that'd be juice to the gills better
office yeah yeah you do yeah vodka what
kind what kind of wait you think you'll
get up to 286 well no you're making 265
get off [ __ ] your brother 65 yeah that's
all right well suck some water weight
you will get you walking around at 286
will suck down 420 pounds that I do how
do you like that I'm saying wheel is I'm
the one who's gonna be involved to come
with a warm bath and a razor blade sure
does your thing your Valley
yes [ __ ] Jack I want you guy no doubt
I want you to have tits just little
little lactating and mr. steroid ten
tiny little [ __ ] whopper balls
oh yeah just little ball speaking of
candy [ __ ] this story Hey
[ __ ] this hypothetical situation uh yet
my dad's in town so I was like man you
guys want the best ice cream in the
world so I took an assault and strong
huh no I got it's all right nothing
pisses me off more when they don't agree
with me right I'm like oh it's better
you're [ __ ] Bonnie Brae ice cream in
Denver you know what [ __ ] you guys if
you drove me nuts but they have an ice
cream they're called candy copia and
it's only there I think candy come come
on tonight's the last night so I'm gonna
stock up stock that we should after this
we burned it but they it's all the best
candies in like this vanilla butter milk
ice cream but it's like whoppers Heath
bars Snickers milky way's it's all
ground up put in sighs food
don't say gee whiz because it come
there's a coming excite or drive diocese
no man no come on give me someone I know
it was [ __ ] delicious though yeah and
it was some of the best I read sounds
good I have my dad trainers yeah all
right he gets on that heavy nuts yeah
some people can't give it up some people
can't like some people feel like if they
tell you that what you're showing them
is something they haven't seen before I
think you look naive I fake it to make
them look good unless that might be the
best of it you talk about the kid he
used to get his hair cut it'd be a
terrible job and I'd be like it looks
amazing like I didn't want to hurt their
feelings my sister yeah me I was like it
looks really thank you for cutting all
the hair off the side of my head and
keep you super ha well I try to try to
do without I tried doing it without
hurting their feelings like you've
thought [ __ ] they're like oh no you know
what looks actually looks pretty good
you're right now is there any way you
could just and you try to like given
tonight you don't hurt their feelings
yeah yeah yeah I I don't like hurting
people's feelings I feel bad about it
me too oh god I'm the worst I can't I
don't tell the truth because my friends
used to say to me go dude I can't tell
me the truth how does it look it looks
great yeah you [ __ ] would say that
and it's like it's true I can he do man
yeah and then Anthony Joshua fought it
was tough
what's his name Carlos tonic yeah tough
as [ __ ] though they're all gonna be
tough at that
yeah but you know he had 12 days notice
shows up competing but not too bad tell
you what definitely early stoppage how
big of a beast is Anthony Joshua 75
thousand sold out before that fight 90
thousand sold out then your unifight
Wilder and he's like I guess we need to
adhere though why would I come to the
states I get the boxing's here it's
never been bigger what do you think of
that fight toy Wilder uh Anthony Joshua
in terms of like who's the most who's
more technical I heard boxers some
professional box with a box and burn
yesterday's talk about their boxes are
box on Terrence parents 12 yeah 12 train
all the lights uh-huh yeah and then
Rashad who was and both of them felt
that Josh was technically more sound
than Daniel
I mean Wilder has a fight this weekend
and then I mean these hypotheticals I
hate breaking down hypotheticals right
now because while it has to fight this
weekend right you know he's fight stuff
but that fight is gonna happen right
Joshua Walter we don't know if while we
lose this weekend it's not happening you
know yeah and then you know with boxing
it does you know the jump through a lot
of red tape in order for that to happen
yeah but then Hertz jump the who's the
promoter over there who's hilarious
there hey Wilder listen you'll love this
they go water said he wants the Joshua
fight he wants ten million dollars for
it and he goes yeah and I want a 10-inch
dick but you don't see that happening do
you he's hilarious
yeah you have you guys seen him no he's
great brilliant and then he gets on the
mic and it there it's not like you know
and Tony its booed here they just don't
like you there it's like the thing that
he's a promoter he's like the suit it's
all Shawn like Joshua gets on the mic
he's like boom boy the promoter people
start booing it's all fun and games
correct he gets on there like what's
next he's like like he goes in not any
specific order but what's next and if
this is true it'd be [ __ ] ridiculous
he goes Wilder Fury and Joshua Parker so
Parker Fury Wilder
look that's all the top die yeah which
is so cool
if fury gets his head together that'd be
really and that would like that I think
that would sell more than Klitschko oh
my god Josh throughout the oh my
but if I'm Joshua I'm like why would I
go to States hold on you want me to
fight Wilder who I'm a way bigger name
then go fight at t-mobile arena which
holds what 17,000 which will sell out or
we can do it here at Wembley and do
90,000 crazy
but and then the pay-per-view here won't
be that big it just won't be right but
there it's gonna be huge
everybody seems to want to fight in
America though that's the market you
want to be Josh wouldn't say that he's
like no he's making so much money if he
can be an American star which he could
be in my opinion it could be big for him
they that that's a guy you want to make
a world world star here's unattended I
mean he has I think one more finance
contract and a Showtime then the the
sweepstakes where anthe JA shoot goes up
and HBO has some crazy power cuz they
don't have a lot of guys they used to
have anymore did have moments ago that
Bob well I listened to your interview
with dr. Wilder and you were talking
about how basically the and you said
this to him and he agreed that the
talent pool in a heavyweight in the
heavyweight division is very very
shallow look how tough was that guy
Joshua fun he's a tough rap stuff it's
fast Turner of him know so it doesn't
matter I do God guys not [ __ ] right
Brooks yeah we broke snows what head but
we can tough his [ __ ] though yeah yeah
yeah I mean people go I've never heard
of that guy or this guy's week now I was
Joshua fighting tougher guys in Wilder
yes right now but man wildest tried to
fight these guys and you guys keep
getting busted for steroids
is that I didn't know that his last
three opponents that's why it's been
delayed Wow
so you know he's trying to get these
fights going he was at force fights to
Russell's funky I didn't think there was
steroids in boxing yeah I love men I
just like I want it there I wanna hitch
I wouldn't think steroids would help you
if I go yeah that's why I do the sports
drama we said no because I wouldn't
think that steroids would help you in
boxing like I don't think they
traditionally did like punching power
it's a 12-round fight it's more aerobic
all that stuff yeah I said it Wow
do you think stereos have been around
for a long time in a boxing yes you do
yes all right yeah I mean it's
professional sports you know better than
this I know better you were just track
of you talking my name and make
the wrestling and stuff like that ma I
just wonder about boxing I just always
thought getting me you know you ever
seen Evander Holyfield fight well that
was usually Mike Tyson I feel it's a
freak and just look that way does he
yeah you think that was the case yeah
that's why don't that's like you know
it's so stupid it bothers but we haven't
so much smarter we haven't you're
smarter than no no we haven't seen any
we haven't seen a lot until maybe
recently cuz I haven't heard of it a lot
of people get caught in boxing because
part of the business well well that's
like saying now we never saw guys in
2003 it caught a lot in baseball because
they weren't testing yeah cuz it helped
the sport having said MMA well we
haven't seen all you guys get caught to
you Sonic game it's cuz they hired you
sada before it wasn't ya to get caught
you're you you're basically failing that
the test of getting cop you're not
feelin test of steroids you gotta be a
[ __ ] to get caught if you're not under
the esata flag right cuz you know that
let us be we don't need a me know better
professional sports professional sports
yes yeah boxing I always thought you
know like I would look at guys like for
example Kelly Pavlik who looked like you
know doesn't look like he was taking
steroids hmm you know I mean certain
boxers like certain Mexican boxers I say
I'll be like doesn't look like it looks
more like they're spending a lot of time
a little bit extra size so if they're a
blood doping yes steroids no so you
think I would blood dope but not take
this - no no no because because if you
are taking steroids testosterone
testosterone derivatives which put on
muscle fat cut but also put our muscles
as we know must sometimes twelve rounds
that's a lot of muscle to feed can't
doesn't help you this is rough
conversation have caused it because if
you don't know how the way steroids work
the top the profile it's different
no yeah I mean so the top so when people
go he takes steroids you get so big
can't make weight it's just well no
that's the it's just so far this is such
a deep conversation be that but like but
Xterra steroids and and and put on
weight bit it's not necessary yeah so
that I don't know that yeah I don't
think a lot of other people know that
actually I really don't I don't think a
lot of like people who watch sports know
a lot about steroids like I don't know
that you know I
know that because you can see you're
saying they're there of course that make
would make sense I believe blood doping
would make a lot of sense as a boxer
have you ever seen Marquez he's dyslexic
yes Ilana's and he thought he was clean
at 40 well no just in general you
thought he was clean I don't know I mean
I I don't think when I look at his body
I don't I don't think that he's put up
bring up Marquez like I know I'm at 40
though yeah if you said he's doing
Sara's wouldn't surprise me right but
but at you know yes he like in a lot of
cases like right up there like it
certainly is he just looks like a
muscular like a thin muscular guy mm-hmm
you know I'm saying but again I don't
know would you would if we're going off
I test would you assume phaidor was on
it oh no I would not assume that he was
on it because he didn't have any jack
yeah and that's when I see so when I see
a guy veined up with crazy lats and flat
I mean there's no strands on service
then I go you know the nature of the
sport and how you train with a lot of
times make you lose weight or you'll get
skinnier unless you're lifting weights
and stuff it's hard to put on weight so
a lot of like to traditional boxers like
Julio Chavez or certain guys there Kelly
Pavlik I'm thinking about I'm trying
some other guys who have a boxing
physique
Mikey Garcia certain guys they tend to
look a little bit more they're smoother
right right so so said it's 12 rounds
you know you can't get tired or you got
it your win means a lot it's all
footwork you're training like you're
running 12 miles a day it becomes an
aerobic exercise there I would say that
steroids is I know them where they make
you stronger and stuff like that aren't
gonna help you but obviously they help
you recover to help you with your
explosion and all that so I hope you'll
speed yeah so alright I'm standing I
stand naive I stand naive would you say
Bob would you say in the higher levels
steroids are almost the norm
Sports is not I'm not seeing our boxers
yours yeah all right
they give like if you watch that for
what's called an increase the the
documentary on Russian blood doping oh
yeah
crazy did you watch the state no but I
should I read a lot about it yeah you
gotta watch it so you get more grass the
state the state was the state itself of
the state the country yeah
the country of Russia and if you think
they're the only ones doing that you're
getting crazy I gotta watch that really
good yeah Wow a caress yeah cuz some guy
yeah came out yeah I think about
baseball and tell me if you think this
is true I feel like baseball players now
because I watched that crazy game last
night I feel like their bodies look
different part of it might be they're
wearing baggy or uniforms but I feel
like that you don't see guys who look
that jacked anymore
and maybe it's because they're testing
more please we would go excuse me well
that's a dad that's the exception that
guy's a [ __ ] he looks like Sammy Sosa
but a lot of the other guys I fee and
I'm not saying they're not doing it but
I feel like whatever the case I don't go
off I test a it's a bums me out you
growing off like this I don't that
doesn't work that bums me out yeah
that's all I could you know better be I
know but you've been around sports with
me like you know better yeah but the one
thing that I mean to a drawl did we talk
about the son last show talked a little
bit about adderall bad Ron baseball's I
hate Joel it's just wait really is it
welcome do it helps you focus oh and
it's not illegal and they're so the
prescription in the a drawl it's just
what you do but now if everyone's on
adderall is in the advantage if your
pitchers don't need the pitch on that
wrong you're hitting a mad wrong the guy
catching the balls on that wrong well
that catchers on that that's the age-old
question is like beta-blockers you know
better you know a beta blockers are yes
so so certain people that have an
audition for the musicians they get
nervous and they have an audition for a
choir or whatever or whatever it is if
you take beta blockers that keep you
calmer is that a performance-enhancing
drug you know where do you draw the line
so yeah adderall is a big one
I don't mind it though they're gonna do
it baseball's never been more exciting I
mean this series been amazing just the
two titans of baseball just doing work I
feel bad for those pitchers III just say
went through those rings I was like on
me to the heaven the rest roster I
looked it up they have ten each team has
ten I don't know
each team st I didn't know that meant
brought them up and that there's only
two laughing like what the [ __ ] are they
gonna do is they're like what do they do
if you run out of if they say it about
the ass that was stressed like what if
they run out right who's gonna throw the
[ __ ] like itch and then this is what
else I got hi did something about this
why is the manager dressed like the
players why are the managers in the same
goddamn out they said the manager of the
Houston Astros was basically said he
only trusts two of his pitchers like
everybody else he throws in there and
pulls him out he was pulling me
Clarion out now I feel bad for but the
Asian guy for the for the Dodgers was
like you know they're like you're ready
goes that guy feel pretty good
oh [ __ ] three-run homer things like you
know I got some bench top are you tell
this like it's such a bummer those are
the best hitters in the world as two
guys leading teams in the world yeah if
you throw a fastball down the pike for
that guy who's four foot eleven from
Venezuela
Altuve MVP he's key hitting that ball
it's how great he's I was like why is
that guy so short is that the camera
angle five six
good for him yeah man incredible I'm not
a huge baseball fan but this serie has
been fun everyone LA's like Dodgers like
I've got them you know what and and I
want to say this publicly if you did it
- no I did you did - weird Vegas - I
would love if we could have the Dodgers
game on tonight I went like this I've
been a Dodgers fan for almost oh no she
was dead serious when we first landed I
love water table game yeah take it easy
I like it
no come on no we were going to dinner
Brian goes uh is there anyone get the
dog just came I was like oh shot that
this is my problem with it when shut the
[ __ ] up
now watch one game all my point is this
I love watching the playoffs and I love
watching I love watching the brace for
the pennant and I love watching the
World Series that's all I can do but but
having said that actually everyone we're
now I'm rooting I
I am rooting for the Houston Astros two
reasons one who won the [ __ ] flood
all right and to plug and two I don't
think that people live in LA I just
don't feel like there are any real
[ __ ] sports fans yeah me too I don't
want to hear about the Dodgers for the
next year right you were never a goddamn
fan correct and also my bike cuz you
know Joanna's a big Dodgers fan and her
full family's big dogs and her brother
every time he's doing hit home write not
go Houston strong Houston trunk house
take you some strong Houston strong just
a piss Lamar oh my god the Astros are
fun to watch me yes they're fun to watch
they come back I like the guy I forget
to the name he's one of their best
players but he didn't have you suppose
keep the ball in front he especially in
baseball right and he don't photo and he
was the camera zoomed in his facing
seems just like ah he's next up at bat
first week sorry about that error well
Minute Maid Park from when I cuz I kept
wondering why there are so many home
runs are just so many like doubles and
it is with the exception maybe of my
high it's the easiest it's the shortest
or the shortest or the eat looked at up
or something because I'm not it leads
the pack in home on Z but it can't be
well that's what I heard but I don't
think you can say it's these particular
woman let's just go short us because
they have the most talent so that's I
saying the team was most talent yeah I
took a picture of the website where is
it well there you go
no no no go back go back which is the
easiest ballpark hit home run mlb.com
scroll down depending on the website cuz
well this is mlb.com so that's kind of
importantly yeah statcast
step course field second-most Yankee
Stadium Yankee Stadium has the most
since the Evans home on either barreled
north song contact that's important so a
lot of them a lot of them so so you can
hit a non barreled or not not make solid
contact and still had a home run in
Minute Maid that's why it was leading
the pack well no it doesn't lead the pie
be so New Yorker Colorado uh nope
because from what I read minute made
this is Emily I look worse field has
yielded the second most home homers of
any ball pardon that field behind only
Yankee Stadium but as it turns out there
are eight ballparks with a higher
percentage of homers that weren't either
barrel saw contact led by Minute Maid
Park media yeah so many men it is it's
it is I was like looking at it go and
this doesn't make these kids it because
it is it because it's a shorter field I
think it might be a shorter wall and
shorter field
cuz these guys are hitting the upper
decks man it was [ __ ] nuts it was
cool yeah they should basic I mean I
only like comers they should do more
fields only like home they should do
more fields with shorter here's another
thing I heard that's floating around
that the balls have more bounce to them
that the balls are different than they I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't either
complete it more interesting
I want them juice to the gills do you
write how fun it was when Sammy Sosa
mark we're going back home
we're onion with a bat yeah it was the
best yes yes oh there you go World
Series ballparks
compared by the numbers to get Minute
Maid it's now they're doing Game six
here in LA
wow just a demon Minute Maid Park of
vastly different in terms of outfield
dimensions high temperatures last time
they played there was a hundred three or
a hundred when they kicked off don't say
kicked off ever again yeah baseball
though as exciting as that game was it
was like in some say it's the best Game
five of all time the World Series
I fell asleep it's baseball it was five
hours simply too long for a you know
maybe it's cuz I can see their faces up
close and I see the dot that I see that
the pitcher when he [ __ ] up and he has
to go sit there take a seat he's alone
nobody's up to him this bummer oh and
it's just like and then the elation on
their faces when they they pull out the
impossible so yes yes hey it week
yeah these boys are just hitting some
home or so yeah Justin Bobby goes down
to game seven and he
how's that keeps us strong yeah I'm
excited
I don't want Houston closed out here in
LA let me go back wording is so much
hatred I'm sorry
we're also because I because I it's I
like to wear a real Dodgers fans but
people I know pretend to be Dodgers fans
I think they're liars and it makes me
angry
me too I'm like like what even since the
[ __ ] fuel of the fires when we land
in Las Vegas right man I need to see
that Dodge game away well there we go
I'm off the track I'm done I'm done I'm
out I want the Dodgers loose now like
you did it I hope you're happy when you
said that one I can't have that man I
don't want to win anymore you know talk
about baseball ever should do some Kern
events current events current events
with Qin yeah yeah it's none of my big
hose let's go piss off this [ __ ] hack
from hot piss
yeah good hop this hot-ass when I say
hot I mean it burns and I have an STD
here's the crabs I have crabs crabs yeah
you read through crabs we do this
weekend Chen would need a jump on that
mic for us Chen what you do first
mmm Jay I'm being cryptic again Friday I
went to escape the show oh that was that
uh yeah I was like it's a rave festival
whatever in San Bernardino could you do
no drugs no I didn't zero no I don't
know you didn't toot up a little bit
yeah I don't think - I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do when you toots and stuff
up your nose you well you hate you doing
you say no to drugs that's like you say
no to drugs oh I do I don't ever I've
done it before you do any open it what
no I don't think I've never taken no
just you don't throw a couple pills in
your mouth you liked out Devils uh
lettuce though that's what I did like so
how's recovering from all my surgeries
it was just like angel dust right no man
I'm asking questions good girl
I was a nun on Friday I didn't do the
babydoll outfit I did you dressed up as
a nun yeah it's gonna do you the girl
baby it all from sucker punch and I went
on Wednesday night to the Halloween
store and like everything
already sold out so so heard from head
to toe in black
I had a black long-sleeve god damn it
those festivals girls are pretty like
pretty it's like oh how long is an
excuse for girls dressed like [ __ ] and
get a free man I encouraged I was
actually a good girl though really we
danced and as a nun just like how many
was how many we're in your group our
group dwindled down I only have one
photo from the night so I was like three
of us but we just like went around throw
different call late were you out I
didn't get home till like 5:00 what yeah
there was no no uppers involved no
coffee no Red Bull I drink a lot of nos
energy drink is nos energy drink code
for cocaine no I would never I was way
too you drinking NAS now do you have a
time machine from 2007 I like it
whatever did did you talk about like and
just have [ __ ] buckets of it in your
closet where'd you get it from drink tab
for him they don't sell it they do Red
Bull and monster there but I don't do
Red Bull hormones so where do you buy
nos at these anywhere I'm telling you
everywhere sells not really reach out
the loop I guess that's what you like
though yeah go I don't drink a lot of
energy drinks anymore I drink alcohol or
no yeah drink alcohol I had a little bit
of sailor on Friday so I'd like a couple
drinks before we're all know it's like a
long drive San Bernardino
oh do you know what I had do you have
Campari soda I sure did we're [ __ ] a
night I was like you know what my voice
went up tone you know what have a
Campari decided to start things all your
gentlemen that's right is it nice it was
delicious
listen it it was wonderful Todd yeah
it's my favorite drink it was very good
I haven't drink it down yeah yeah I'm so
proud of it and I have taken two as you
know us because I'm a gentleman
gentleman I have taken to sipping good
and fine Japanese with Japanese with you
only for you those right on the rocks
sir yeah on the rocks can't do Jack
Daniels I said no no no no that's for
peasantry I'm yeah that Daniel or what
about Johnnie Walker Blue it's that's
that's you're getting closer to my to my
genre palette you're getting closer to
my genre to my palette here we drink
Japanese E
I prefer to die first and in a smoking
jacket and sip my Japanese whiskey and
judgin only Japanese though huh yes I
typically only go with Chinese yes and I
will I will I will get involved in a
very expensive good sipping on yaho
a Mexican ano a tequila an ale
so I've been known to do that as well
what's your drink of choice MJ Jameson
for sure straight Jameson Wow why is
that James the core he's like maker's
mark my first drink at 21 was makers
mark and cherry coke my mouth is
watering
they still make cherry coke used but
Gretna diamond coke let me ask you
something MJ you're had a Pepsi clear no
see I didn't like tasted it though I've
seen it you had cherry 7up
cherry 7up don't they have a cranberry
7up the holiday times they have a really
good 7up that's like a cranberry 7up j7o
sure has it's delicious I'll say this I
was thirsty
I've never drink soda ever and my buddy
had a coca-cola classic
in a in a glass bottle and he poured
that [ __ ] on the ice and I tasted it and
it might be the best thing I've ever had
in my life was the Mexican one that's
maybe retain the [ __ ] it yeah sure
it was cane sugar mm-hmm it was the best
thing I've been probably right I think
they raided I just don't drink soda so I
went god damn I get it see I feel like
when you don't drink you ain't right
like Oh like if you if you're constantly
drinking it your palate gets used to it
you like it tastes good what do you
don't drink it then like I used to drink
a shitload of diet drinks like a
shitload all the time I'm like you know
I'm going no artificial sweeteners I'm
not doing any sweeteners anymore and
then so I don't do any stevia and my
black coffee with all milk I don't do
any sodas and then I had a diet coke
Riesling and I can taste the chemicals
yes but you don't Saigon so if you're
off of it
same with coke if I drink coke now it
tastes like pure [ __ ]
yeah your dad a coke last Wednesday we
had a diet pet see you and I had a Diet
Pepsi when we got to the Paris hotel
terrible though we got yours Pierce
Hotel oh boy oh boy the hotel why did we
have a Pepsi
oh wait where's the buffet yeah which
was actually pretty good the prime rib
was pretty fresh
yeah but happily we had soup we had a
couple diet Pepsi's and and I wolf that
down it was nice
yeah what's your drink of choice chin
alcohol well yeah let's go with that
call first
Oh soju Korean so G so when we all go to
Ukraine barbecue we can all have it what
so cheese never happen it's like a rice
wine well I don't look like is it like
sake that remind of so it's like they
make good barley too but it's it's kind
of like a Korean version of vodka half
the percentage of alcohol though I like
I like I like it's okay okay it to me is
unfiltered sake cold unfiltered playing
it cold
that's hot sake tastes like sake bunch
shut the [ __ ] lower quality it feels
good though hot sake what do you mean if
you're sick no no when you eat sushi
I like I wanna I want to show your fear
that you're fit what let me take that
drink out of it what about like a drink
weed no not really
maybe if anything I'll drink beer when
we're on the road yeah beer if anything
it's IPAs yeah I do like a bitter do you
like you nicely not a beer guy man I'm
done with beer I might be I'm gonna done
with ourselves wine is tough for me now
because I can't what your wine oh I have
trouble sleeping I'm gonna be honest
with you it was very to say you've got
you you know what I mean I'm a little
embarrassed right now and I hate to
since you are you sure doing it down no
you should do one stop wine stop wearing
[ __ ] black business socks like they
should go hand in hand
thank you see wooly cuz if you're giving
if you didn't give up wine it easy now
give up your black business sock you
need your [ __ ] tennis shoes be gentle
with me [ __ ] what do i what do i wear
white shoes socks here no what kind of
socks Tyler
I'll send you some teach me Stan to help
Shalit stance
for richer for help to not literally
anything but those [ __ ] men to my
house my bladder PO
baggie don't say this don't say take
that back apologize next level he's got
Paisley on them what would you do what
do I have on today although these these
are the big ones yeah
what do you what did you do this weekend
chin I gotta be honest yeah me and Brian
talk behind your back I know we don't
know what the [ __ ] you do yeah I think
you're sneaky goose I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you guys something after this but
uh no this weekend I did a lot of stuff
about this company about this show
finally kid yeah so I'll tell you about
as far as the live stuff no the video
element already told you about the other
our budget for hookers finally figure
that out because I mean super annoyed
with me by spend out the ass I don't I
don't want any hookers I want girls who
need help with their rent who's like
don't know any of those so that's what
you did this weekend just figuring that
up to companies but then also now that
enough time has passed by I can kind of
talk about that girl oh the dating girl
the gender chick oh did so when I sent
you guys a the message in the group text
it was a picture and a video yes you
guys got both right yes okay good please
tell me she was a man no so I told you
the next date I checked on her because
we stayed up super late yeah so I was
like just checking to see if you got
home okay and all our stuff it's fine
and then she's the one asked to go
singing again mm-hmm Kennedy dokie so
did that and then I don't want to talk
about it like literally the day after
cuz I don't want her to find out that
we're talking about that you're
discussing me every move yeah okay so I
got you so during that date something
really really bad happened that freaked
me out I think I told MJ I'm I don't
know if I told you not you guys you guys
are sharing these stories and not
including me if anything kinda pissed me
cares I'm sure you know okay so during
the time we were went to like a Korean
restaurant to drink I'm gonna cry she
sets up then she's super religious and
she said something that was it actually
freaked me out
so she was she when she started opening
up to me yeah she told me straight out
she goes oh my god I can't believe you
know you said that cuz I said something
like you know how we met her friends no
my friends whatever so I put some stuff
together she say death to whities if she
goes oh my god you don't you don't
understand I knew I always had this I
talked to God
so she says she talks to God and I
freaking out destroyed every really
really was she a freak though because
typically my experience with girls who
talk to God and that are religious now
have a license to just gobble see this
is my I'm if she would have where I talk
god I'm like that's so weird sometimes
he talks to me I just got one hey God
just told me you need to suck my dick in
this yeah filthy my experiences they
simply dive on your dog in fact they
want to skip dessert and just did dive
on it in the bathroom and throw the
Bible away that's only my experience
yeah because they've done their penance
and now they're gonna go church on
Sunday and get fully redeem there's
women who talk to God who are that I
have no problem with religious people I
don't like me neither
whatever but maybe she just maybe she
was well but was she super religious
where she was weird you know I'm saying
okay the very first instead of that date
she's Christian Christian yeah but
sometimes I can just be I talk to God
know so I asked her what do you mean
well you mean you talk to God like what
happens she goes you know you FaceTime
your mom my FaceTime Jesus but yeah
he'll tell me stuff I can hear him
telling me stuff I said all right cool
did she say what kind of stuff like
moves that she should make she should do
this and then good things will happen
and I didn't go to how she doing in her
life she seems pretty well all right
like she's killing it some people can
can get I don't know if it's killing it
I don't want to say where she works at
but she does maybe she's talking about
her in her voice you know why would you
phrase it that way that's such a V she
leaves just being informed by get like
she's being guided you know sometimes
religious people can just talk all the
way and it doesn't mean that they're
crazy it just means that they what you
know so I go how do you how does he talk
to you he tells me things she can hear
his voice telling him things so that
that's just like
so any kind of cool stuff I had before
it just kind of went away that's why I
didn't text back for playing hard to get
and then she hit me up again you're
hoping Jesus would tell her to text you
I don't mind that like go to Center Tex
whoops she said I need a speck
what if you'd said so you would actually
hook up with her knowing this yeah if
you were single I would what what I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] unless you had to
be more than mine unless she was more
like if she was like came in God steered
my life I talked to God literally I'm
talking him right now like there's crazy
then there's people are just religious
yeah religious tightly if that's your
thing yeah and I that's cool man
I have friends who are balls deeper
really and we still get along but
there's been crazy let me ask you this
paka she is crazy if she said if she
said yeah I prayed on it and then I came
to a decision like I was different if
she if she was talking with that's Jesus
[ __ ] and it's good that's an egg yes
that's what it felt like that's what she
did I hate that way right she just said
I talked to God I got it I know I had a
girl who was perfect and then she said
she talks to the Lord and she went
through all this and I remember being
bummed out because I was like I don't
that's hard for me to identify with it
was just hard for me to you know pursue
Christian I'm not super religious but I
would never say that oh I can hear a
voice that tells me what I should do to
like you know help my life my friends
who are more religious than her and they
wouldn't say they thought you guys are
all going to help but I mean that's fine
too definitely because he's [ __ ] Oh have
you heard from her since I told you she
just recently hey Matt oh what'd she say
so she she had like a thing with her how
do I get to into detail but we went to
karaoke at one time big random in
Koreatown so when we were there we
bought I bought bottles and I guess some
Baba's and if you don't finish a bottle
they keep it for you well that's nice so
she hit me up saying like they're
celebrating something and she didn't ask
if I what if I wanted to go so she said
she phrased it like is it cool if we use
your bottle at that place for uh it's
her it's her damn it almost is well it
was her brother's birthday right okay so
she says she we're golden for my
brother's birth
cool if we finished the bottle yeah but
she's played you dude that's why she's
reaching out exactly so in after that
she writes and if you want to come along
you know you can come to it that was her
she invited it's nice though I know
she's cute she's freaking hot she's
super hot until you just taking off the
table too
I think it's weird like I said before I
think I'm just too nice if I did
something with her and knowing I'm not
I'm not gonna go over there I'm not
gonna be with her how do you know you
might I don't want to you don't want to
be with your I mean that if she's
talking to God a freaky [ __ ] yeah if
she's too religious I can't [ __ ] with it
either if they're that I wanna just it
just it kind of puts a damper on it you
know if I'm a just bone and didn't and
leave that and say that is so jacked up
so is it now that's how I feel feel like
she's gonna push it on you is that why
you're afraid no no I just think she's
weird yeah yeah I get that sometimes you
meet people too yesterday I was at the
growing my family and this the nicest
looking lady ever came think of the nice
woman you ever seen she goes he goes hey
how are you doing today I'm like pretty
good you know you I don't really talk to
strangers I'm like pretty good she goes
do you have any pains or anything like
where do I start
you know like just I'm there with my son
yeah I'm like where do I start she goes
well let me know because I'm gonna pray
over you you're gonna feel hon percent
better what oh no no no I don't I don't
I don't want that and then she went to
my dad any pains my that's like two
actually my ankles kind of bother me
she's like I'm gonna pray over to my dad
but she was going around the Grove she
wasn't crazy now she like kind of had
her [ __ ] together just friendly his
[ __ ] my favorite was a guy so I got
her number 49 and she wants to finish
the bottle she'd love to finish the
bottle Friday night there so now you
just you have fur kind of whatever I'm
up in the air right now I don't honestly
don't know what I'm gonna do with that
one but well no good news and bad news
for you yeah good news is a harmony is
about to run some spots on this show oh
yeah and they're gonna hook yes that's a
true story
er man he is gonna be a swine Oh
yeah excited I had a guy do this to me
watch this he goes I said what'd he do
he goes get rid of pain in fear I go I
was like D you guys yeah so ask me just
questions
that's what I do what do you do I get
rid of pain in fear oh yeah yeah oh you
got pain yeah I do
God you got fear sometimes gun you work
with me God nope oh wow yeah it doesn't
exist
after you work with me oh well so I love
this so I go really
so then we have a he gives me an
introductory class and I love a [ __ ]
train wreck and I love a con man so I go
you went oh yeah yeah how old are those
probably 15 years ago
oh I don't matter cuz I just wanted to I
was so yeah I'm talking about look him
up on the internet or anything
I actually liked him because he said
something interesting to me he got you I
said he works with people and I said
what about me what would you say about
meetings uh you he says hang inside
places you have one idea of strength and
there are different strengths and I said
whoa and he said he said your idea of
strength is you know like like dogs if a
dog fought a cat what would happen I got
a dog killer cat he goes yeah but what
if but but but could the dog catch the
cat and I was like oh yeah it was just a
different thing that God you know you
know do you just waste all your time in
my face [ __ ] about you're not a dog
and cats have their own strengths it was
that it was a long conversation you know
there's different kind strings which we
had a good conversation about we get to
his place and he has he has a glass of
water because there's some water for you
and I go to read for you is not yet
don't don't read for you that's why good
I'm letting it sit in the Sun because
when the water sits in the Sun it
absorbs the sun's energy and you'll feel
much much more power and I'll just pray
this is done this is oh he's up no but I
loved it I went through the hypnosis he
hypnotized you'd allowed him to
hypnotize he goes he goes out he goes
what are you afraid of it like you know
wake up with you take it was great then
he came out with a robe I die I won't
say this gentleman some of us you know
he's but I
worked with this mental coach and I
didn't know he was not that it matters
but just raging gay I had no idea you
know I went to his place and Morin land
out with their I don't know they said
born was with me
well because long as like let's see how
good this guy is and Lauren sitting
there and then you know he's doing the
whole stuff like breathing close your
eyes breathing and then he looks over at
Lauren's we're bright half an hour and
he goes do you mind live in the room
because it's better for just me and
Brendan oh yeah no problem
he leaves and then I just feel him
behind he's gone and his breath is on my
problem yeah I was like cotton pad on
never saw him again never saw him again
he didn't touch you though huh he
touched me no not my private part but
all over my back and my dick on my back
because you're because you were and
Lauren Jose we got attention look we got
done Lauren goes bro no no no what he
was - he tried [ __ ] you in there I'm
like basically but I didn't let it
happen but anyways that yeah Jen you
need when you get you set up with that
lady at the Grove she can pray for panic
oh he harmony sounds good though
you harmony legit huh I like that do you
want hit on you MJ at these uh these
parties these raves or not yeah you just
don't have I don't I don't know I was
with like just shut us down
I don't know I'm just not not like time
right now to be dating on too much stuff
going on I have another class I just
started I'm so overwhelmed oh I
appreciate you empty do you say I make
that a mention you 40s are you religious
you are now now you are no chin what
happens if you just met this [ __ ]
diabete she's a 10 but she's Muslim as
[ __ ] and I need to convert no no no ah
you know really well you saying you are
a Christian I'm Christian but are you
though no no question is that she wants
to raise your children her religion yes
yeah be brought out the big question is
she's a 10 I'm talking high school
you've ever seen
all you had is convert bro she could
worship Satan I'm in yes she could have
her own [ __ ] play code again ok no
problem
every morning I guess / - the chickens
throat - suck on your titties in yeah
you a hoodoo
you convert Sharon black magic voodoo
bring it off your [ __ ] [ __ ] Trump's
at all especially if she's cool yeah I'm
not religious dude I think all of you
would convert at the same to Muslim a
hundred percent oh my god I'm surprised
oh praise a lot no fork see you all same
time same guy I think we're all praying
Muslim God are all the same I think for
the pearly gates just no matter how
you're gonna get it actually makes it
more simple alright five times a day
though convert right now yeah I don't
know she yeah y'all are dirty evens
[Laughter]
current events with chin chin attend hm
alright the first chin ups oh yeah this
is fascinating you know that journalist
that was murdered on a submarine or
supposedly murdered on a sudden I sure
know what happened in August's first of
all ya tell us she was trying to
interview a guy who made his home-built
submarine and then she went missing her
body turned up later on he's a wealthy
guy like super wealthy the right
industrialists or something I don't know
isn't his wealth thing but so she turned
like her pieces of her body turned up
later it's kind of gross yeah that's a
fascist Danish inventor has admitted
dismembering the body of Swedish
journalist Kim wall and his probably
built submarine first of all don't build
own submarine but continues to deny
killing her who was a cute he's so he's
accused of murdering wall he claims she
died of carbon monoxide poisoning while
he was on deck yeah the progress they
found on his computer drive a lot of
stuff video of women getting their heads
cut off so now he says but originally
said she died accident he hit her head
on a hatch yes I mean I was the first
thing he said he's keep scrolling down
he's serial killer is he a serial killer
yeah multiple hey they just know that
they know that he when you have a bunch
of video on your computer of you know
women getting their heads dike so it
says mass in kids denied charges of
murder and sexual acts other than
intercourse charge stemming from the
fact that wall had 14 stab wounds around
her genital area man
Christ what a terrible man what a
terrible [ __ ] about your family think
about our family I'm gonna deal with
that piece of [ __ ]
he's a crazy person man so yeah he
denies that he murdered her but he did
admit that he chopped her up yeah okay I
guess yeah well so she hit her head so
then I said to stab her in a general
area of 14 times cut her head off and
cut her body off oh and by the way on my
computer I have video yes video women
being tortured and having the head
collar yeah but you're normally sure she
hit her head off do you find them they
did investigations first of all this is
investigations yeah dude first of all
you know how hard is to cut up bodies I
don't buy I imagine it's pretty [ __ ]
I do
oops no yeah man it's really awful
that's so terrible you know and if you
can get off on just the fact that you
mishandle a corpse then he will get off
but there's no way he gets off right I
hope not it's this is but is this in a
Danish Court I don't know how they do
things
what else you got chin let's see you
okay Corey Feldman he was on The Today
Show he said he's gonna release all the
names of the big Hollywood guys that are
pedophiles did you see this yeah I did I
watched the interview live actually but
he's not saying him now that's what
people are pressing him know why he's
not saying it now because he's like
because I need to raise ten million
dollars to make it a movie yeah and then
I forget to get the it's not doing so
better his name was like well you are
you just doing it so you make the ten
million dollars are you doing a
documentaries like no not a documentary
it's a featured film yeah it's like ah
that's my problems I don't quite buy it
I'm sure there I know there are
pedophiles in Hollywood and I know as a
child actor dealing with it but I think
he is being a bit of an opportunist here
it feels like already weight raised two
hundred thousand dollars but he said
he's not saying it now cuz he's afraid
of like legal action taken against him
yeah said he needs the lawyers and stuff
to protect him and yeah movie he the
last time I heard he was singing
national anthems it like things aren't
going so well for me yeah see I think I
think they get molested I think he has
the names
I think it's Bulger I think it's both
which it doesn't mean what he's doing
is wrong like I got molested saying hey
I'll make this money I'm not doing [ __ ]
either but if I'm gonna do it I need ten
million before I release a name for you
guys [ __ ] me so I I like both sides I
hope it works out for him
but I also feel like now like it's the
thing to do like people are just coming
out NASA now I think it's great that
there's a voice and they feel safe
enough if it actually did happen but you
can tell some people are just looking
for a feel like he's be yeah you feel
like he's being a bit of an opportunist
like the way he's he's being dramatic
about I watched the interview and I'm
like man see I don't mind that because
kids are a problem he's like listen this
is what's going on if he's gonna release
it but I feel like there's something me
too so that happened I mean let me ask
so if you know children are being
molested okay you know that why wouldn't
you come out earlier to save children
from being molested
why if their children are being molested
you know if they're you know that name
yeah and and they're gay molested right
now forty something right and now you're
coming out how interesting now but you
but I guess those kids who all been
molested by these pedophiles well I'm
gonna wait to the right time this is
where I get a little bit of a problem
this where I'm like it's so interesting
that now with all this focus you're
coming out now I don't know so what's
here come out though we put some names
though didn't he
yeah the Matt Morgan he named like you
didn't name one I think one or two
people in the memoir but he said that in
1993 he was interviewed by a Santa
Barbara Police Department he says if
anyone was to go dig around it's in
there like he gave names today yeah no
doubt I don't as they said they were
only looking for Michael Jackson yeah he
never did anything to me these are the
guy well I guess it's in if it's gonna
come out before his movie cuz if it's in
those statements they're gonna release
well now Kevin Spacey's been accused by
rap up next okay go for it
yeah well he's been a go ahead chin okay
so yeah Kevin Spacey was accused of not
like molest oh is it molest see what
happened was trying to get on down rap
was for saying rap what's the full
course we don't have any rap Anthony
Rapp so Anthony Rapp I guess what turns
out was in he was a God I saw that play
two long day's journey tonight but so so
Anthony Rapp and there he had a party at
his house this wasn't Kevin was 20
six when no one knew him right he was
like a stage actor this is 14 years ago
uh and the rap was born this was 30
years ago sadly rap was 14 years old was
30 years ago a long time we do so so
apparently Adam let's go is bored at
this party and he goes into a room and
it's Kevin Spacey bedroom and he's
watching a game or something
all of a sudden he realizes he's the
last guy in the room Kevin comes in
really drunk and lays on top of him
mm-hmm and kind of like you know maybe
rubs on him but then gets off there
wasn't any penetration I think there was
no nakedness but got on top of him and
I'm sure the kid at 14 was like get me
the [ __ ] out of Dodge right and got out
you know and ran out that's what
happened now Kevin's face says he
doesn't remember it but to his credit he
said I don't remember it but I I
apologize I'm beyond horrified to hear
the story I honestly don't remember that
he counter it would have been over 30
years ago but if I did behave that and
as he describes that wholeness and
serious apology for that would have been
deeply inappropriate drunken behavior
goes I'm day and then he goes out so gbt
community has a huge problem with that
because what they're accused of doing is
confabulating is that the word
conflating conflating the conflating the
two so you're you're you're you're you
molested a fourteen-year-old boys makes
you a bit of a pedophile and then you
are conflating that with being gay yeah
you're overshadows yeah and Kevin Spacey
has always been pretty in the closet
about being gay for a lot of reasons I
ever know I have no problem with that
let him let him make his own choice to
come out and I think he's an amazing
actor and I think that they're really
mad but I think he was also going when I
when I say this the next question is Oh
Kevin Spacey's gays let me head off the
charge that's what he was trying to do I
so I believe in this situation you have
to give somebody the benefit that's all
so is that really if I'm what the rap
what the [ __ ] this guy's had every right
if I'm Adam Rapp is it that big of a
deal to come out like yeah he laid on
top of me I agree are you are you that
traumatized great room that's mine I've
had worse [ __ ] doesn't happen to me yeah
I got I got kicked in the head by two
got three guys I mean you know there's
certain things that happen that are a
little bit more this is what I this is
where the
they should be well you start getting a
fighter I'm just saying I'm saying like
no I got beat up by three dudes but what
I'm saying we didn't get no what I'm
saying is that let's let's just talk for
a second about like you to your point
like okay can we make a distinction
between sexual assault and groping or
inappropriate behavior because let me
just say something if you get accused of
sexual assault that is that is in many
ways can be a life ruiner there's
something about those two words that are
very heated sexual assault or okay so if
George Bush grabbed your ass or if
somebody felt your breast or if somebody
like you know maybe put their hand on my
dick for a second you know and we all of
which has happened to most of us in one
time or another okay by our mail or
whatever is that sexual assault or is
that inappropriate groping doesn't there
have to be a conversation about the
difference that's I think yeah I think
it's a fine line to like I would say
Kevin Spacey set you assaulted this kid
I don't think so and also I am safe I
don't all the details if it's true what
you said where he just was like drunk is
on the bed and just jumped on top oh my
god yeah let's look up what Anthony Rapp
says because that's what that's what it
was and so again I agree with you it's
always like I don't know man like he's a
- ramat eyes or you just trying to
capitalize on Kevin Spacey's Fame then
let me ask you this would you have said
anything if Kevin Spacey wasn't famous
once again why didn't you come out
earlier if this was because then God
will not save cuz all the women are
doing it well bro you know is he picked
me up like a groom's picks up the bride
over the threshold but I don't like
squirm away initially because I'm like
what's going on and then he lays down on
top of me okay he was trying to seduce
me not know if I used the language but I
was aware that he was trying to get with
me sexually
eventually the actor pushed Bischoff and
he left see I'm sorry I just think the
reason why so well the issue is he's 14
that's the time you sure that's a huge
issue I don't condone that at all so
yeah it's [ __ ] up he's 14 it's a grown
man that's super creepy huh yeah it's
like now if he was 20
and he did that now then it's Kevin
Spacey taking he's missing taking the
swing the problem is this is a child
yeah that's the issue imagine - for you
then he's ten
yeah no you can't do that 14 is 14 but
14 still under age 14 still retains a
kid now yeah so now I guess a [ __ ] Kevin
Spacey
yeah well Warwick team yeah yeah yeah
but again what did he do he was drunk
[ __ ] saw him I don't know what how drunk
he was got on top of him or picked him
up and got on top of him and got pushed
off probably was like a [ __ ] I
shouldn't be doing this we all do crazy
[ __ ] to 14y even I've been drunk
hey [ __ ] ah he don't give a low pass
game drunk doesn't turn me into a
pedophile but I'm saying what I'm saying
is that I just think that there is a
difference here between sexual assault
and that and even though the kid he was
a kid yes I would say that sexual
assault the [ __ ] up part I think it's
inappropriate but what makes it [ __ ]
up it seems a lot older and hits a child
yeah that does of course it but it's not
sexual assault what it is Kevin Spacey's
better but a lot of people are being
accused of sexual assault for things
that are like to me
inappropriate behavior advances right
sexual harassment is a very complicated
issue which I get and a lot of times you
don't have any recourse but but sexual
assault versus inappropriate groping
well I I don't know how we can you can
you bring up the definition of sexual
assault because I don't know how you
like how do you how do you do because
it's an assault so so is if I push you
it's assault - but if I break your nose
it's a salt any type of sexual conduct
or behavior that occurs without the
expert content of the recipient I think
it's too broad falling under the deficit
of sexual or sexual activities are for
sexual intercourse forceful so vomiting
Shawn molestation incest fun all right
attempted rape that makes sense if your
attempted rape if you forcible sodomy
yes sexual in spawned lling how do you
define fondling alright so is this
sexual assault if after the show I go up
and I grab MJ's boob is that sexual
assault or what would that I don't
believe that sexual don't call it I
believe that would be another lawyer
behavior right I think that'd be what do
you think is a woman let's get a woman's
perspective here cuz you're weaker and
you're you have to deal with this right
so a jaw guy like Brendan a big guy or
anybody what do you how do you look at
this be honest I think it's all
situational like if I was at a workplace
and that happened I would definitely
feel like that's more of an assault
because you're in a work environment
yeah but if I was out at like a bar and
a drunk guy did it
then I'd be like all right get off and
then I'd feel like that's more of a salt
but if it's like a one time thing and
then he stops like I think then that's a
that should be considered like you said
like a grope and you know minor
indiscretion right kids like it [ __ ]
happens it's happened that's happened to
me at a bar where guys like y'all drunk
and like touching me and like just go
away get off dude yeah I better grow my
dick in the bar yeah so you're not gonna
like go to the police and be like hey
this girl grabbed me you know and like
make a scene out of it like she was
drunk like so I think it comes down to
like I think it really comes down to
like you have a human being in front of
you are you going to humiliate that
person alright so okay so so here's like
if you're if are you the kind of guy
you're really attracted to her
I understand passion right need to start
kissing you grad you know but if you're
the kind of guy who looks at her you
don't know her very well and you grab
her by the crotch and then you grab it
like to me like that's a song yeah
like to me you're being a [ __ ] also a
huge [ __ ] right and I feel like um
but it would does that is that with
Kevin Spacey I think if he's known for
this and behind the scenes behind the
shadows like he's known for doings two
boys 14 year-olds and he Scouts are
using his power for guys that he's a set
with then we have an issue yeah you know
what I'm worried about I'm worried about
like so you're making out with a girl
and you're getting crazy and then you
reach down or pants and you didn't get
explicit consent but her body is telling
you one thing and you're both together
do we we don't have to stop romance here
do we you know what I mean and sometimes
I worry that we're getting so we're
getting so [ __ ] crazy about this
stuff that all I started this little
difficulty with it is July was like 14
yeah
getting on top of them obviously none of
us are we see a grown man on a 14 year
old you were not gonna go you know we're
gonna drag that [ __ ] off him you know
what I mean but um
I just think we have to have that
conversation I guess it's situational
situation situation I mean I think this
honestly was probably a good drunken
mistake and a huge drunken mistake it's
a minor anything's a minor I mean you
should get that usually I you should
that hit on the wrist and you should you
should get in trouble for it but did it
did Anthony Rapp come out and say this
because he thinks other kids have been
subjected to this no or like what's the
point of him singing now like why
everyone's coming up but so what's he do
career well it's like what did Lee Raab
do I don't know he's still after a Star
Trek or something yeah they said Star
Trek like do you think other people are
we coming forward about Kent I should
know why you would do it like yeah it
doesn't was he sharing some experience
like I don't know it's this culture now
where it's just like yeah if you can
think about any time where it was kind
of iffy like got it that's a big name
like I'm like a are you know saying
earlier if this isn't Kevin Spacey's not
[ __ ] Kevin Spacey do you say anything
probably not that's what bums me out
there's like this witch hunt for goddamn
it that one time like you guys are these
actors and actors sitting around with
her buddies like oh my god do you really
one time 17 years ago in New Orleans
with insert famous actor he came on to
me and grabbed my neck and we were all
drunk and I was making out with them and
they said let's [ __ ] I told him no and
he got all nasty oh we should tell that
story it's like well why are you doing
it now
yeah he's also not doing his career
isn't huge you know yeah I didn't even
know he was so this rap guy yeah notnot
hurlan no he's been doing alright that's
that's that it's a big cast on Star Trek
it's not can you go down and see what TV
or there's theater okay a lot of theater
always a lot of theater um super
talented yeah oh yeah yeah I don't know
I don't know what the motivation is
behind that I don't know
I've skeptical hip boys well I'm not I'm
not saying any of its alright and it's
[ __ ] up but Spacey did switch students
a child but if he was a girl let's see
who's 21 or 18 he did that well right
yeah shut the feeder up
yeah he just a guy who tried to [ __ ] it
yeah yeah come on I mean what else it's
progressive so no have you're having
major issues
there's a difference between that -
isn't it different in a guy who like is
really aggressive and a guy who makes a
pass at you complete differently you
gotta you know if there's a guy like you
know you how many times has been shut
down by your odds are it's like baseball
three out of ten you in the Hall of Fame
right you know I'm saying right so guys
are gonna try and it's you know it's
hard to get the hot girl yep have you
have you got any issues with it all
right I mean I think every girl has I
know when I was in high school I was at
COC says freshman year I was on the
dance company at COC I was walking to
class and this older like football
player he's talked with all the older
girls there would come around and hang
out and I remember one time he like
pushed me against the building it was
like hey I know zit get off get off and
he's like oh hey do you wanna go with an
older guy I heard you had a first kiss
and I'm like screaming at this point
like that like I probably should have
said something you know like what if he
knew I was 14 like he knew I was a
freshman I was freshman in high school
these were all like jasiek junior
college girls you know so I mean like
there's things like that and he's a 19
year old big football player yeah that's
strange
so there's weird things like that but I
mean I think most girls just don't come
forward you just have to brush it off
and other guys a creep I mean there's
other times that's happened to I feel
like I came to think of the top of my
head tapping on bars every girl has
story yeah sure Joe is a million story
she's so pretty like yeah I'm sure a
million guys have tried like grabbing
her but you know like I said to my wife
I was like are you kidding
yes concen entertainment she said yes
and I'm sure some dark [ __ ] you said to
brush it off that kind of sucks it's one
of those things like it was a persistent
the same person produces the attractive
girls and women men are gonna want to
have sex with you right most men are
gonna have sexy and then within that
category of men there are some wanna be
clumsy [ __ ] use them run out there's
a lot of them are harmless I'm like I
[ __ ] you just really attractive yeah
okay what we gonna start we're gonna
same day if they keep pushing forward I
think that's when you have to push back
and then say something but if it happens
once and then they stop they listen to
you then it's kind of something you just
let it go yeah but I think they keep
pushing then you have to push back
because you can't just keep getting put
into a corner no no yeah and I was
reading this this interview
for he was on but is this famous soccer
player super famous and it's crazy
stories like a three part series and I
was reading one of my [ __ ] flights
were delayed and he went to play for his
hometown he's like a soccer god hero and
he starts getting these weird texts like
threaten him and tell him oh we saw
you're rolling around with the Mafia
guys and you know we know you're into
child porn he's like what the [ __ ]
ignores it then he starts to get mail at
his house his parents house say you know
you like these Photoshop picture of him
with kids and stuff he's like black
tough [ __ ] man super famous soccer
player and he's like what the hell is
going on so he calls a old friend who's
an investigator who's in on it
and the guys like this is what we got to
do so he starts do it years go by in a
start getting worse way worse and this
investigator was like don't worry I'll
take care of it we're gonna figure this
out and he'd help them and do this stuff
and go away for a little bit then it'd
come back really bad gonna wait for a
little bit come back really bad and
years go by it starts to affect his play
on the field because he goes I'd be
playing the game and a half time I check
my phone and say hey we know where your
parents are saying we're gonna murdered
your kids and just the worst [ __ ] you
can see he's like how the [ __ ] do they
know all this stuff years go by it was
that investment source it turns out that
he was doing like several people to get
help so he would say that they would
hire him well so that he would so he'd
get free tickets of the game the guy
would sign anything he want from he's
doing to this restaurant he'd get free
food there he's doing to this rich guy
who owned the house cuz the guy would
lend him his house he should act like
you sell Brielle so sure and they caught
him
they caught him and you know how they
caught him is because he was on a boat
is his dad like a like a real stern dude
and he was like god I I just feel like
it might be this guy in like no way them
that scared like they were boys like
best friends they're on a boat and he
goes what's wrong inside this [ __ ]
diamond he didn't tell him what he did
he was this [ __ ] guy man he's doing
this this thing is what about the child
molestation stuff and he never said
anything do about thing is holy [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy that's when I figured
it out Wow
crazy story Wow super creepy yeah that's
always
who's next to you mm-hmm it's like the
guy who so this is where I want to admit
that I'm the one who's been saying those
DMZ painted faces on it you - MJ's been
me it's been me with elephant ears
painted on the [ __ ] you guys excited
for Halloween know who is at our age am
i right I can't wait to watch the kids
hey I love watching them trick or do you
think you doing MJ here and then how
many new Nellie's big there's like we
had parties yeah because the whole
entertainment business so you have to
legit like costumes like people look
like straight up like you'll have the
makeup artist from the walking dead do
your makeup it's like Jesus Christ I
come in with my team are now facing me
and Tiger and Joe have the same outfits
we both the black skeleton it's cute the
family next door hired like the Game of
Thrones [ __ ] studio artists are you
[ __ ] them digs are you doing anything
chin yes sleep off the lights so kids
don't write the next current event
no no sketch in a boy fell over the
railing on Niagara Falls because my mom
was trying to take a picture of him what
have you seen this no he's up there he's
like take him up yeah that's incredible
hundred foot fall under foot fall you
hit his head and he was listening in
critical condition in the beginning but
now he's in stable good I'm so glad so
that's all that happened believe so
that's a pretty big well but he didn't
did he break anything or nothing just a
little key just his head they just said
he hurt his head and he was airlifted so
they're now you know Niagara Falls has
an emergency team there they saved him
got him ready to go in the helicopter
helicopter took him to the hospital he's
good can you imagine mom like three -
yeah God why would there be reeling that
as a spirit is there no video of it no
no the camera probably has a chin holy
[ __ ] look at that driver killed when 12
real dependence suicide falls on a car I
have that one to hold very versed [ __ ]
why show me kids trying suicide like
it's like the cool thing day and it's
even crazier to cuz this lady or she's
only like 20 come on what is it Jim so
yeah the twelve-year-old jumped over the
onto her car but then she actually was
going to school for helping kids with
developmental disabilities and like
things like this behavioral disabilities
that she was gonna learn in the high
school she was getting a master's degree
in that she was working on a master's
master's degree for that to help kids
like this crazy irony yeah oh my god
clinical counseling at Milan University
is gonna sound [ __ ] up this is gonna
sound really [ __ ] up but in a way she
saved that kid's life he's 12
they said she had a gift working with
children she was young as [ __ ] yeah
super young man what a bummer
all right what else he gets in alright
uh so you guys seen this dirty right bu
League and I haven't seen this I heard
people talking about what happened so
when I think was that homerun you're
talking about when Ono was down the one
when Darvish got the Darvish is the
asian half asian half Iranian or
something okay I forgot he was but he
looked Asian though yeah he looks he's
half Japanese he pitched and then this
guy Yuri you Lee Gyuri I'll hit a home
run and then right after he wanted to
the dugout he you know did that thing
that why would he do that cuz he just
hit a home run on that Japanese guy so
he just goes he does is that pinches his
eyes back and he goes she needs though
something like that which is derogatory
term for Asia
[ __ ] what do you do that and think you'd
get away with it yeah and you're certain
the World Series gala the World Series
yeah and he was suspended but not for
the World Series of course not so [ __ ] I
think those five games into 2018 and
then check out Darvish his response
which is really cool
no one is perfect that includes both you
and I what he had done today isn't right
but I believe we should put our effort
into learning rather than to
guy if we can take something from this
and it's a giant step for mankind since
we were living in such a wonderful world
let's stay positive and move forward
instead of focusing on anger everyone
sir him on your pocket well done yeah
[Laughter]
good for him what the [ __ ] was that guy
thinking it sounds funny that happens a
lot though dude especially like Asians
are still you can still make fun of
Asian well I grew up with I'm not sure
what you lee is I think he might be what
what do you think he is first of all
stop everything sir you do a terrible
and offensive Asian accent we never had
we had Tony hence clip being an Asian
woman this isn't that if you're on a
comedy show I'm on the world series
completely they're still the group that
people can make fun because they could
people are like there's doing so well
yeah but see he's human right he's Cuban
the most racism I ever ever faced when I
was growing up was from Spanish people
so Mexicans would do it constantly
really that thing and then you know do
you member like little schoolyard Ryan
that goes ccino ccino hop-ons go make a
condo me this no are you you obviously
memorized it - yes constantly by
Mexicans would just like be hardcore
racist against Asians it was just the
way it was when we grew up yeah even
though they were my best friends but
then they're also like the mean ones we
were horrible yeah wait racism doesn't
isn't just black white on black it's
it's personal it's Spanish for some
reason the Spanish people more than any
other race Latian white people black
Asian whatever obviously Asian but
anything else there they weren't as
racist it was a Spanish people that are
hardcore on us how about the MLB we
don't [ __ ] this series up your spine
fight games next year it's too close I
don't want anybody spending
Wow I I mean what were you thinking
though it's such a bad idea
yeah he said he also knew that it was
bad like what he was doing was bad yeah
he just did it
yeah yeah well what else you get that's
well
don't uh okay so there's this guy who
cuts homeless people's hair for free
he's done thousands already and his name
is Brennan Jones
that story got around to another guy who
was a barber who actually was building a
new barber shop and he actually gave him
the keys to that barber shop to give him
so he actually gave him a barber shop
yeah that's thick yeah one of the things
so he couldn't you know cut all the love
that strap now is he just gonna cut
bumps here's an icon one like on a
special day but the rest is just a
regular channel I'll go and the guy that
gave him that stuff you don't know III
well next time I'm in Philly I might
just go by ya go to black barber shop
see what he does you're here I want to
fade I want to fade damn it I want some
roses what I want that's what I really
hope that's not racist at all so the guy
that got on that shop he was also like
he was headed troubled beginnings he was
incarcerated turn his life around
became a business owner so it's a good
story all the way around yeah good for
them man what else you got love it
getting positive do I owe this is a
crazy so there's a sex doll brothel yeah
in Spain Barcelona right and they have
to start turning away customers because
they want to get a little too crazy with
the dolls how do you so crazy a brothel
goes nah bro get out of here what do you
think it is that they're trying to earn
them or cut them tomorrow Marin
headlocks what are they doing trying to
punch him fulfilling rape fantasies Oh
which I'm guessing I'd rather homegrown
out a doll and get their Andreessen I
would agree let him do it on on a plat
on a silicon doll and not on a real
human being so this is the Barcelona
brothel replaced women with busty sex
also allow clients to act out their
wildest fantasies things they would
never do in person with a real good way
to figure out who the serial killer
rapist is I'm going to town the DA he's
beating the [ __ ] out of the DA so we
should probably keep him away from the
women owners Sergey Brito was forced to
turn away some sick individuals who
wanted to act out a rape fantasy
how do you go all right yeah look at
that doll I'm not giving her
I would not there's only so there's a
lot in the world all sessions around $90
for 30 minutes they're only for talked
about drinking for public copper there
for dogs
how will you clean these [ __ ] dog
that antibacterial cleaners are
encouraged to wear condoms with each
doll encouraged all right you know
encouraged you know walk yourself I
don't I'll buy my own doll and then not
use it but we kind of [ __ ] psycho
with having sex with a doll when there's
real women next somebody who likes
having sex are dead like a necrophiliac
you know what I mean
you're a necrophiliac but you don't want
to admit you have no access to a funeral
home we got the next best thing
so let's just go ahead and since they
can act out their craziest fantasies
they don't want to do it on real women
because they can arrest all those guys
that say sex robots they got their
developing sex robots that are mighty
fine and oh and then there's that have
you seen this new thing porn now is
being watched with virtual reality and
also they have sent they have like musky
scents and stuff and it's really very
realistic mr. bean those dolls duh the
hard pass for me $210 for two hours $210
yeah you're a D [ __ ] mind
can you imagine all right man so we got
Kimberly over this she's real and then
we got Kim she's real and then for $210
you and you in [ __ ] that doll over
there does anybody know I'll go with the
doll if you're with your friends and the
guys like I'll take the dog you're like
oh I gotta keep you away from everybody
I know the doll and dog don't it one
more this one another teacher sent a
student nudes on snapchat but she also
she had sex with him twice they found
out she's not bad looking at all I don't
know and I appreciate it she's 26 right
so she's pretty younger and it was a
high school student and now she's facing
possibility of 15 years 15 years cuz she
had said to them and sent them some snap
points yeah this is a reboot it I don't
agree three felony had
be under 18 conduct involvement was 17
and a stud no that's not okay you can't
do that
no no why no yeah at 17 I would I would
have I would I would have given
everything that fought at 26 girls and
they did it consensually - yeah but - 15
years
you think you deserve 15 years I yeah Oh
15 years - 17 you meet me when I was 17
I would have [ __ ] did you read me when
I was 16 I would have done whatever I
couldn't [ __ ] I'm not kidding yeah
out of money yeah this is not the same
as a boy I'm sorry boys are like we
don't give a [ __ ] that's our biggest
fantasy yeah it ain't the same for some
in but then some teachers you could say
our sexual predators love it's a shy kid
and she's like oh alright well I can
mess with an mentally well in this case
1413 yeah they met multiple times I mean
I'm thinking of my sounds like they
understand relationship right and then
she shouldn't do 17 years he consented
obviously you can't consent but he did
consent to it yeah umbrella
this whole it's tough when you're a boy
and then if you read through the text
and the guys like I can't wait to [ __ ]
you miss yeah yeah man I mean I don't
know how all the kid was but 17 you 17
right under 18 that's all I'm just
making a high school student
yeah Pisa anywhere fees wonder 15 we got
problems anywhere from 14 to 17 but I
highly doubt someone that's 14 I don't
know I can it kind of bums me out cuz no
teacher made a pass at me not I know I'm
[ __ ] I agree with you not I would
have I would have I would have been so
pumped I had like one like really Aysen
teacher though dude my dick was always
hard at say I know but did you have any
hot teachers mmm no one won I'd won once
you expand you on but it was 18 and the
rumor was my buddy did hook up with her
she was so hot she was 22 my buddy he
was 18 he was a man-child yeah he could
use 18 yeah that's nice oh no he was 17
oh that's it was our senior year so he's
good yeah yeah nothing man do young
teachers ever hit on you MJ
I had a substitute teacher oh he was
pretty hot no yeah but I mean I was such
an awkward little being I still AM so I
didn't do anything but I'm like I'm
pretty sure like he's up with somebody
really yeah like you just used like
smoking hot likes like flirty like so
hot and he had a twin brother he was
actually part of like the media industry
- oh shoot
so the plot thickens if he actually did
anything but we had a we had a hot high
school lacrosse teacher he was the coach
for the women's team Wow and yeah I
guess he just like boned all the girls
out there and like you we knew about it
well girls at the girls we got fifteen
sixteen seventeen are often and very
commonly attracted to a 26 year old stud
teacher you out of your mind
this is natural as apple pie the track
coach at my school would take like this
one with the chat girls like out to
lunch all the time inside when I worked
at the diner in my town I would see them
like Sunday mornings on like a you
didn't practice super weird
she was beautiful this girl like she
looked like she's 21 but she's 1516 I
know he's got I got weird hey read some
suit teachers got what a tough gig kids
just didn't listen to you weird one
substitute teacher that came with a
guitar and I was like this can't be good
we're in tenth grade my desk in our
urban school man he gets up there's like
I am I'm your substitute teacher I'm mr.
Smith and before we get into social
studies today mostly black kids in
school I'm a play a little song starts
playing like John Mayer some [ __ ]
halfway through you saw he's alright you
know what you could test it like brokest
so two teachers man substitute teachers
and stepmoms tough [ __ ] goes man yeah
you have to be substitute teachers were
the worst no one put up with you you're
not gonna do [ __ ] you're there for a day
usually just put on a video because
everyone knows no one respects you
yeah she's put on video you just push
play make sure no one dies substitute
teachers man don't make my shitty deal
terrible deal don't they only make like
$15 off any a substitute teacher like
they're on call for god sakes yeah I
I know cause I had to do it LA Unified
district it's tough
oof yeah done it Jim that's it but I
would say the time I ever tell you how
am i directed a play in in a school that
was for kids that were not allowed in LA
Unified they were the kids that had to
be put in a special school every day
that yeah and I went in there and I had
to drive the scene
I don't can't remember for the life of
me how I got roped into this and I would
drive a way out and the my star my
[ __ ] star of this other play the day
before the play the cops came into the
classroom and let him out in handcuffs
and I was like [ __ ] I got a play and
they go well I go what do we get like to
get your play I had to I had to [ __ ]
figure out and so well then I had
another kid who had to hold the script
and they did it for the whole school it
was a [ __ ] disaster he got arrested
right there for what selling drugs
that's good it's good
16 [ __ ] you tell me acting was in this
path [ __ ] I was trying to give them in
motivational speeches that's all there's
beef they thanked me for sticking it out
cuz nobody is there for these kids
that's like I know but you know and then
this is the possible sixteen is like do
you like to get faded you should come
get failure with us and very flirtatious
I was young you'd been Letizia
yeah that's very very you know but again
it's not trouble because I'm not a not
crazy I'm not gonna go to jail for like
you know oh the sixteen-year-old didn't
love me I'm here director play I'm not
she was clearly you know but yeah
alright I'll just not do it
how's that sound I just not do that not
go to because yeah I don't go to prison
I'm there to director play the rich in
that's it that's hilarious
you're dropping Oz be smart your
instincts it's right here and I'm just
gonna recommend this book only because
this guy helps huge corporations kind of
like think outside the box right but
more importantly he draws on all the
available science like for how see most
of us don't really know how we think
like most of us don't really understand
how our brains think but one of the main
things that we do to get in our way is
we basically basically say I'm I'm no
good like I did this is not for me you
know it's called negativity bias like
bad is always stronger than good so when
you're in a group and you're working
with people the guy who says that won't
work always gets more status and because
we've evolved to always think of the
unknown as bad because again if there
you hear a rustling in the leaves the
dude who goes toward the leaves and goes
that must be a gazelle gets eaten by the
tiger right so that's something you have
to kind of fight and the other thing is
available availability bias we do this a
lot where you what you see basically is
all there is so you'll see people have a
point of view on something and they will
basically because they have experience
with something they'll basically say oh
it's this so you can ask somebody it's
kind of like CrossFitters look at the
whole world as a gym it's almost like if
you if all you have is a hammer you're
gonna see every problem as a nail you
know it's the same idea and it's very
hard you have to think your way out of
that because we've our brain has evolved
that way and then and then of course
there are a couple others that I'm not
going to go through but status quo bias
which is the idea that let's just stick
with what we have so so a lot of people
I notice a lot of young people want to
make a difference in their lives that
want to change I want to make a change
it's good to take an inventory of how
your brain thinks because a lot of times
you just get in the way you're on your
own [ __ ] you get scared you go on a
negative tippity bias you're going to
confirmation bias you're going to a
status quo bias which is like I'll just
stick with what Burton hands better than
you know is better than two in a bush
right I'll just stick I'll stick with
this and you get real tight and then
it's so I won't go through the whole
thing but it's a really it's a really
[ __ ] good book and it's really easy
to read it's by Adam Hanson it's called
outsmart your instincts and and I think
it's a really important like thing to do
is you get older to kind of like take
inventory there's a lot of science to
teach you how you think and that way
when you start to think about a problem
or you
an issue you'll you'll be able to
recognize how your brain works and how
your brain stops you and we all suffer
from the same [ __ ] always confirmation
biases the [ __ ] big one but that's
that's the one where you basically
ignore anything that contradicts what
your preconceived notion was we always
do that
like you will find evidence you'll
ignore the evidence it's that's counter
to your feelings and you'll find
evidence that supports your guys be on
the lookout for that because we all
suffer from that so it's called outsmart
your instincts little baby go get the
book good book and we did a podcast on
mixed mental arts calm alright actually
just more importantly come see me
November 17 18 at the Gotham comedy club
and then I'll be at wise guys in Utah
Thanksgiving weekend and then Cobbs
comedy club December 7 8 and 9 in San
Francisco this Friday
I'm in Colusa casino the tour kicks off
this Friday November 3rd Colusa casino
and then the following weekend I am in
Charlotte comedy zone then Friday
Saturday so I'm in Charlotte Thursday
next Thursday comedy zone Charlotte
almost sold out zannies Nashville
Tennessee fought November 10th 11th then
that Sunday I'm at the funny bone in
Columbus Ohio Colusa Friday then the
following week Charlotte Nashville
Columbus get tickets now tea fat K calm
calm this is the fine kid route